[Music]
hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Tom Holland has supposedly
leaked at a title for the next
spider-man movie I haven't seen the
video on his Instagram yet so I kind of
wanted to watch that first before going
into this video though patron the day
shout-out for Derek Mitchell been
talking with you lately buddy it seems
like you're doing alright these days
you're not killing people doing your
uber and glad you cut back on the serial
killing what I wanted to say to you guys
was Derek Mitchell has actually started
up a YouTube channel called tales from a
rideshare driver he is talent stories
funny crazy stories and tips for uber
drivers and riders as well it's gonna
come for a guy's been doing uber for a
long time you can get some fun stories
from him tales from a rideshare driver I
love you and you love me more than I
love you but john loves us both more
than we love him or more than you love
each other so you know whoa this is
becoming a Mexican standoff whoa of love
great time
meaning everyone's going really well
noise I wanted to apologize because
there's no real revelations coming out
this weekend about spider-man 2 I don't
know much about it I'm a little confused
because I've died so I don't really know
how it all comes into play but I do know
is I've got the new script super excited
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
far from home that's funny because Tom
Holland and Mark Ruffalo had the
reputation for constantly spoiling
things but I like how they it's very
cheeky though he's making fun of the
fact that he's known for spoiling stuff
is doing it in a way like this is an
accident I didn't mean today that's
actually really cluckin physical comedy
because so much of the audience is in
the know
of this is Tom Hollands reputation for
doing something like he's talking about
spider-man we're gonna find out
something about they know when it comes
to the secrets
it's called far from home is just an
obvious implicator that he's gonna be
way outside of his comfort zone on this
one I do enjoy the concept of that very
much okay a little fish-out-of-water
action maybe yeah Marvel's good at that
and flopping mm-hmm trying to breathe
suffocating fish do an actual fish out
of water a movie it's like 127 hours but
with a fish reliving the parts of life
the fish can't remember because fish
don't have that luck just remembering
the past is like over and over and over
again it's an interesting title far from
home yeah like for the first other be
homecoming and this one far from home
showing a different departure oh this is
perfect Collider you have set up your
site perfectly for us to riff off of
here dude I was thinking of this exact
quote where at Kevin Feige says we start
filming in early July we film in London
we shot first film in Atlanta and we
shoot a lot of films in London but
there's another reason we're shooting on
it which is yes Spidy of course we'll
spend some time in New York but it also
spend some time in other parts of the
globe
hey which is an interesting part a
factor to me I mean when I heard that
like that's cool because most of the
time other than the Avengers movies he
is constantly just in New York yeah all
the spider-man
like standalone films turf I feel like
with the Tobey Maguire one or even the
Andrew Garfield one that would make more
sense yes after something like the
events of infinity war it's not that big
of a stretch playing spider-man for him
to actually be back on earth amia some
other part of the globe it's just he's
still a high school kid so I'm wondering
what his mission would be that would
cause him to actually have to go to some
other part of the globe would it be
Avengers related or is this the kind of
thing where he's gonna be back in
regular school on like a study abroad
thing and then see a nun or something or
is it gonna pick up right after whatever
it happens in Avengers 4 to reverse all
of this and he's like having to find
himself or something but then again like
you know Mysterio supposed to be in this
movie
they say spend some time
or even vultures supposed to return as
well wait how is this film gonna work
exactly because it's gonna be in some
other part of the world while he's gone
is Mysterio raising hell in New York or
something or is he following him
maybe that's the whole fight of the
stories like he's away and the Mysterio
attacks New York he's got to get home to
fight him he's so far from home that
it's gonna take a while cuz he can't
just web sling back from Europe that is
an intriguing title because it makes you
wonder what does that exactly imply yeah
and it sort of infers that it's gonna go
you know broadly away from the themes in
the territory of the first movie like
it's a direct reference to that which is
cool and it's an immediate implication
to that PD name peedee peedee peedee
peedee peedee it's a it's very youthful
name what's it like this short nickname
for Peter little PD Parker I don't think
I've heard it very often but maybe in
passing in a couple look at insult bTW
it's not the most flattering to all the
Peters out there a bunch of pd's alright
guys well is this a satisfying subtitle
for you hmm
is this YouTube for a question annoying
you guys can subscribe the reject nation
hey click that notification Bell why cuz
subscribe buttons are broken you can
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage become a patron eject today bye